we're happy to invite though to talk
about pcps and hyperconductivity for
Global functions
so thank you norm and thank you all for
coming to this talk so in this talk I'm
actually there are not going to be any
four-way positions that are going to be
some Boolean functions still the theme
but I'm going to tell you about how this
notion of global level connectivity and
all of this
much of what Max was talking about was
sort of motivated by some recent PCP
stuff so basically I'm going to tell you
a little bit about PCP without assuming
that you're familiar with it too much
and then slowly but surely we're going
to convert you some boy analysis stuff
so here's the talk-out client
so first of all I'm going to tell you
what is the PCB theorem you know the
most basic vanilla is previewing from
the 90s
and then some classical consequences of
it and this will show you the gap
between what we know how to achieve from
the Pacific theorem what we don't know
about you then we'll ask ourselves how
can we improve upon these things
and this will let us lead us to a strong
formulation of the busy Victory which is
better but still not good enough
and this will motivate you against which
is really you know the main player here
which if
you know that this is hard and we know
essentially everything
and we'll talk about the consequences
and then eventually I'm going to talk
about this lesson PCP stuff namely the
two to one or two two games theorem and
how this is related to Global hyper
connectivity and all of these fun stuff
okay so let's start with the very basic
so here are the three such formula you
know we all know and love two formulas
and the most basic question you can ask
is I give you Twista formula and ask you
is it satisfiable or not
so this is seems computationally hard we
don't know how to prove it so we just
declare it that this is empty Harvard
and we just assume that it's computation
indivisible
and once you make this assumption this
is computationally feasible then you can
start proving that other things are also
computationally invisible and you know
this is all Furious and be hardness we
even teach it in other God so this is
all very nice
this is the godstone of as far as the
how Alex is concerned
and how do you cope with happiness well
one way is to relax uh the
satisfiability constraint and ask I give
you a satisfiable formula please satisfy
as many of the Clauses as possible
so I don't ask you to satisfy everything
but I relax it I tell you please satisfy
99 though coming up
so this is when we talk about
approximation or how does approximation
this is the type of tasks that we have
in mind
well with this in mind one formulation
of the PCB theorem says that even
approximating to research is still NPR
which is the following statement it says
that there exists an absolute constant C
less than one
so that even if I give you a three set
formula which is promised to be
satisfiable not only can you not find
the satisfying assignment but rather you
are not even going to find an assignment
to satisfied at least see fraction of
the closers
so this is much stronger than the
standard group living theorem
and indeed you know once we have the
hook living Theory we can start doing
reductions and the same thing goes here
once you have the analog of the book
living theorem for approximation you can
start doing Productions and get harness
of oxidation results for other problems
and of course you know because this is
approximation you cannot do any all
those reduction that you want you have
to do what is called Gap Reserve
introductions
which is more complicated to do but you
know we can still do it
and so once you're equipped with the PCB
theorem and these reductions then you
can start moving whole host results
and I did hear a few results that I
don't know only using this machine
so these are some very classical results
so for threesat you can observe it if
you just choose an assignment randomly
it's going to satisfy seven over eight
of the clothing
and what I said proved is that this is
essentially the best you can do
if I give you a satisfabric formula it's
NPR to satisfy more than seven over
eight
[Music]
and you know for each problem there is
some different factor that we know some
of these are types for example three set
While others I don't know for example
vertex cover or Max scratch
yeah except for each type well depends
if you want to fight about this little
one but yeah
okay so let me just spell out some of
these results just to get the general
flavor of things
it's one problem one very basic problem
in linear algebra is I give you a system
of linear equations and ask you to solve
it
and this is essentially the really
important
so what is a thrilling instance well in
this context because well discrete
people we walk over finite fields and
the most final field is F2 so we're
going to stick to F2
an instance of thrilling consists of a
collection of equations
each one of these form it has three
variables you sum them up and you ask
whether this is equal to b or not will
be some constant in the field
so it's very easy that if I give you
such a system of linear equations and I
tell you that it's completely
satisfiable then you can solve it
because of linearizable
and it's also easy to show that whatever
system I give you you can always do 50
just by choosing a random assignment
and what has that showed is that once
you relax the fully satisfability this
50 is essentially the best you can do
and he proved that it is empty hard to
distinguish between a system which is
almost fully satisfirable
and one where you cannot beat this half
this is one example of harness of
population results that we know how to
prove using PCB
another one is about the click open
so
um yeah so I assume that we all know
what the click is
so if I give you a graph with n vertices
whether this graph contains the click of
size into the one minus Epsilon
or it doesn't even contain a click of
size into the Epsilon
so if you take Direction between these
numbers you see that it's out to
approximate we in fact which is almost
one over n
and this is you know that
but notice that in this case even though
there is a large gap between these two
numbers they are still
small with respect to number of vertices
in the graph it's not like constant
fraction or anything like that
so here's the question can we get an
analogous how this result to The Click
problem but well at least in the yes
case we have some concept fraction of
the vertices forming a click
so as far as you know the hardest
approximation ratio that you get this
doesn't change anything but the problem
clearly becomes easier
so it still makes sense to ask whether
it is out or not
but now remarkably this
this little change makes the problem
much harder to understand and this is
partially understood
so let's say that I tell you that your
graph contains a very very large click
click fifty percent of the vertices
former click
what can you say that
so can you find the click of size 50
this is maybe too optimistic so maybe we
can find a quarter
1 over 16 or
you know
and we don't know how to do any of these
so we actually think that this is hard
but we don't know how to prove it
and it turns out that we need stronger
assumptions to do that
so the PCB theorem even with all of the
extensions that we're going to see
seems insufficient to prove such
statements
so what we're going to do next is try to
discuss some strengthenings of the PCB
theorem that were studied over the last
30 years with the aim of opening such
statements we'll see what they get and
see how to get Beyond them
any questions so far
so to study these strengthenings I'm
going to make a different formulation of
the PCP theorem which is completely
equivalent it's just easier to see the
strengthenings once we use this language
of label
so here's the definition
so level cover is the name of a problem
a computational problem and an instance
of it proceeds as follows
so my instance I'm going to call it PSI
and it consists first of all of a
bipartite buff
I have left right L and right side r
then for each one of the sides I have a
separate alphabet Sigma is the alphabet
of the left side and sigma R is the
alphabet of the right side
and one last thing which is the most
important feature of a label cover
instance is the constraints
for each Edge in the graph I have a
constraint Phi which tells me which
pairs of labels to the left vertex and
right vertex are considered satisfying
and you see that there is this word
projection here
so
usually when you define label cover you
don't have the sword but you know we
want objection so I'm going to skip it
what is meant by both action is that
these constraints are not arbitrary
rather they have at least mild structure
namely for each Edge UV once I tell you
the label of the left side view
there is a unique label for the right
side that satisfy the constraint
or in other words there is a mapping
between
the alphabet of the left side and the
alphabet of the right side
so that if I assign the left die the
value Sigma then the right line Max gay
get the value Phi e of Sigma in order
for the edge to be satisfied
so this is what a label cover instance
is
of course if I give you a level cover
instance so this is a maximization
problem and now I'm going to Define what
is the objection what is the objective
function
of this problem well I give you a level
cover instance your goal is to assign
labels to the vertices
so that as many of the constraints are
satisfied
so I want to maximize the number of
edges a so that if I look at the labels
that I assigned to the end point of view
then this fall inside the collection of
tuples that are considered satisfying
so we'll see an example of how you can
retest three set in this language this
language is a bit
stuck but it captures many things and
it's very useful
let's see an example of how to capture
three South in this language of
laborator
and for that we should have in mind some
three short formula Gene
and right now I'm going to describe to
you how to construct this vibraphone
graph this alphabets and this
constraints so that the label cover that
we have essentially captures the
satisfailability problem of G
so how does it grow well I need to tell
you what is the left what is the right
what are the alphabets and the
consequence
well the left we're going to have a
Vertex for each one of the clauses
so these are these orange vertices
so we're going to have a Vertex for each
one of the variables
now what are the alphabets well
for each vertex on the right is going to
get either 0 1 depending on if we want
to assign that variable zero or assign
it one
in other words assignments to the left
side
describe assignments to the values
and assignments to the left side well
the assignment to each vertex here is
going to specify the assignments to each
one of the variables inside the clause
and I'm only going to allow seven of
eight of the assignments does it satisfy
the clause
so this is how to think about the left
and the right and now the last thing
that I need to do is describe the
constraints
naturally well we if we're available
here X1
we are going to want the assignment that
this X1 gets to be consistent with
whatever it gets on the orange vertex
so this is going to be the constraints
of the level cover instance
so we're going to have an edge between
each clause and each variable
if that variable is contained inside the
clause or its negation
and we're going to demand consistency
so we're going to say that a label for
this vertex
is consistent with this if they give the
same value to X1
and you can convince yourself that you
know in some high level perspective
this level cover instance exactly
captures
the satisfability of three such the
formology
it's not exact the value is not exactly
the same but it really captures in
spirit
so whenever I say level cover you should
really think of this sort of instance in
mind but you know the definition is
modular
so now that we have this level cover
language out of the way I can tell you
an equivalent formulation of the PCP
theorem
the film that says the following
they'll give some absolute value okay
and Epsilon so that if I give you a
label cover instance well the alphabet
size at all constant there's more scale
then it's simply hard to tell whether
the assignments to the level cover that
satisfy all of the constraints
oh
or assignments satisfied most
one main exceptional fraction of the
constraints
so actually if you do the construction
that we did before this is just a
corollary of the previous formulation
but it's really equivalent
yeah
sending glass in a slides on the last
minute is not a good idea so I'm sorry
about that we're going to try to make it
work
um see
I hit the wrong slide and anyway we have
the basically theorem and now we want to
improve it
and well as I said this film is is
strong enough to obtain some results but
it's not strong enough to obtain all of
the results that you want
so we want to strengthen it and there
are two ways that you can think about uh
in order to do that
so one way is to improve the sound is
parameter
so in all of this business I'm going to
have two parameters the completeness
which is what happens in the yes guys
this is what you can do in the good case
and the soundness which is the best you
can do in the knowledge
so in the basic PCP theorem well
you cannot do one more exception but one
reception is still a lot and we want to
improve upon that
so this is what is called the low sound
of sodium and you can hope to prove that
maybe 11 cover is still hard even if you
want to distinguish between fully
satisfied instances
and instances that are at most Epson
satisfied
and this is a little bit case we know
how to do that and this is proved using
what is called parallel repetition field
so this was known for a long time and
really all of the results that we saw
forward fill in for click on all of that
they all they already incorporate all of
these machinery into the picture with
all this we cannot really do anything
so this is one way you can try to
improve upon the basic PCB Fielding
another way is Mozart hello
and in some sense we already saw it
so the constructing label cover are
fairly generic we don't have too much
structure over them
well I'm slightly cheating already
because if you remember I said it's
about the projection constraints and
clearly there are more General families
of constraints
and this projection world is very
important when you do reductions but
projection is still a very rich family
of constraints
so you can hope to obtain stronger
structure over the constraints the more
limited the better
and this is not obvious like you have to
look at the reduction and see that they
actually use this structure a lot
but once you see enough of these things
it becomes clear that the structure of
the constraints is very important
and here unfortunately our understanding
is much more partial
and in some sense so people have been
doing this structural from long time but
it looks like a hack like every time
you see this world smooth file
repetition a smooth PCP so this is
basically a name for a hack to obtain
some structure of the constraint which
is just good enough to obtain the result
that the offers wanted
so here we have a complete understanding
of this a small value with him but the
structure thing is much harder
and as as his life if you want to obtain
the best results you actually have to
obtain both of these things
simultaneously
and I already said we cannot do it in
the best way
and indeed because we cannot do it in
the best possible way this Machinery is
still insufficient for many problems
so for example we
saw the world not external this is one
prominent problem over these sort of
tools are not enough
and if you want to paint that results
you have to go even further
but before we go further the question is
so what would even be the ultimate
combination between these two
improvements
how would it look like and what would it
give us
so we're done with the basic PCB theorem
well done with the consequences and I
did tell you what is the strong PCB
Theory which is basically the small
soundness with some mild structure of
all the constraints
you know I'm going to tell you about
this ultimate combination between all of
these sex which has a name it's called
unique games
and this is a central problem in
complexity Theory
so what are uni games
well any game first of all is a
particular a special type of a label
carbon instance
and it has two additional features
first of all
the alphabet sizes of the two sides are
the same
and in fact you should think of that for
which is just being the same
and secondly for each Edge this
constraint between the alphabets is just
a matching the simplest possible thing
simplest type of constraint you can
think of
or equivalently if you remember we said
that each constraint is defined by some
math
so matching there said that that map is
a one-to-one
again level cover language is a bit
abstract so let's see an example
so let's add it to our bipart.gov
let's say that we have already says
and let's say that the alphabets is just
some field FP
then what would be a unique game over
this
graph well we have the edges
unique for example says devalued it the
left vertex gets minus the value of the
right vertex gets is equal to 4 mod
rupee
in that case whenever I tell you what is
level of X1 there is only one value for
y1 that would satisfy the constraints
and vice versa
so this is one type of thing again
actually in some sense it's the only
type of Union game but uh never mind
that
and whenever I say uni game this is
really what you should have in mind
Okay so
we know what in unigames are now
and the only thing that is clear so far
is that
unigames are just very very special type
of label travel instances
so in principle they may be easier
computationally speaking
and for example here is one aspect in
which they are in fact easier
so if you remember we said if I give you
a level cover instance it's hard to tell
whether it's fully satisfiable or at
most one percent any feather
well for in a game this is no longer the
case
if I give you a uni gaming instance and
I tell you that it's fully satisfiable
then you can just solve it you know in
polynomial time because you guess the
value for one vertex and then you
propagate it over the place there is
only one option each time you propagate
it
so this is easy
well
so what do you do then well you
conjecture that besides this little
satisfability issue any games are still
have them
and this is what he's doing against
conjecture or ugc in short this was made
by subashco in 2002 and it says the
following statement it says okay
if I give you a unique instance file
well the alphabet step size at most okay
it's NPR to tell whether the instance is
almost fully satisfied namely the value
is at least one minus Epsilon
oh the answer is most absolutely started
in other words the informal version of
it is if you ignore the satisfabric
issue unigames of a Justice are this
label is general labor
and every silver thing because
well I'll explain it soon so NP harness
is you know they got standard silver is
you know silver is less than gold so
it's less so this is a conjective it's
still a conjecture but there are many
Works saying well if this conjecture is
true then something else happens so
these are still very good results but
you know it's not empowered so this is
the distinction between gold and silver
and this is what I referred to as you
know the ultimate combination between
small soundness and structure for the
constraints
because you see here the gap between the
S case in the north cases as good as you
can hope for but at the same time
I cannot imagine any you know
simpler type of constraints well this
program can still be conceivably hard
so this is really the best of both
worlds
of course this is just a contraction so
yeah so this UTC business have been has
been around the block for
a while now so naturally there's been a
lot of fork on it
and
roughly speaking you can partition the
work about what you need games into
three types
so one of them is is algorithms
so you know naturally once you define
some computational problem you can try
to design algorithms for it
and indeed starting with the original
playable by subash people have been
trying to do it and
for some classes of graph it works for
some questions it works less well but
the bottom line is that all of this
album items were very sophisticated and
nice they are not able to solve unigames
in general
so they don't bite the condition
but they do give us fairly nice ideas
about what we can hope that how the
union gamuts would look like or whatever
what they cannot look like
this is one type of works that they've
been about tuning games
the other type is the type of fork that
says okay let's assume that unique games
is hard what can we conclude about the
world using it
so here there are many more works I have
only you know three citations here but I
don't want to flood you with you know
Brazilian I'm not a cryptographer
so uh
some very nice neat results of Thai
Thailand's results for vertex travel
so you're probably familiar with the
trivial to approximation algorithmetics
what it says and repeat
algorithm is essentially tight if you
assume UDC
so this was a very nice walk
but and even I think more influential
work was this hardest result for Max
Scott which really opened the floodgates
for consequences of winning games and
following the there have been a lot of
works
and
I hope that I'm not offending anybody by
saying that probably the the most
notable result in this business has been
what the vendors a lot that basically
says that you can look at the class of
constraint satisfaction problems which
is you know a huge class of problems
and assuming you'd see for all of these
problems the best you can do is a
semi-definite programming algorithm
so this is a really you know amazing
result in my opinion like thoughts over
General class of problem is it tells you
what is the best algorithm and why you
cannot do better than it
so you know if you this is true then it
gives us a very nice understanding for
many many problems
and the last type of work is about
ugc is you know it's a conjunction so
let's try to pull it
and there have been some attempts but as
of today the best
or I guess the most uh
[Music]
I guess the best results that you know
about tuning games is what is derived
from the two to one game theory
which is not equivalent but it's
basically equivalent to the following
assertion
which says that the United currency is
true but in this case you cannot achieve
one minus Epsilon but rather some
constant so you have
yeah
so this is the State of Affairs about
uni games
so let me elaborate a little bit about
this consequence of winning games so we
know where in analysis of TCS semester
so analysis should enter the picture at
some point and I will just say that
behind every almost every one of these
consequences lies a very nice analytical
theorem with four coefficiency
influences everything that we like in
this store
so here is an example this is this very
discover result
and here is what it says
I give you an inverted scarf
then it can be hard to tell whether
there is a vertex travel that consists
of at most travel devices
or everybody discover must contain
essentially all of the vertices
this is this seems ridiculous which is a
consequence of any games
in other words when you you know you do
this division problem you get that it's
how to
approximate to impact or two minus
yeah
rather notable consequence is this max
cases
so I hope that most of you are familiar
with the government's Williamson
algorithm for Max cut this is a based on
semi-definite programming you know it's
a very nice algorithm and it achieves
some fun approximation ratio for Max cut
which is roughly this number on the
slide
and what you can show again assuming UBC
is that this algorithm is actually cut
in the sense that forever Epsilon
greater than zero
getting approximation which is just
Epsilon better than this is already
and finally I said that this value is
very general result by the vendra and a
slightly more
a General charging precise formulation
of it says that if I give you any
conspirational distraction problem
then you can write down the
semi-definite program relaxation which
is a very something very generic
then you can solve it and then apply
some you know black magic which is
called the gaussian Randy schemes that
you have no control over but it exists
and if you do all of these things
without even looking at the instance too
much you get the best approximation
possible
again assuming ugc
it's an exciting program has a separate
number uh
[Music]
someone
foreign
like CSP with bounded area right yeah
yeah but the question is like if that is
scale how we should go I don't know it
was quite bad yeah it's still something
fun yeah it's something final but uh
and this is
so behind each one of these results lies
some very nice uh analytical
film and many techniques have been
developed precisely to make these
reductions work
and let me give you an example for one
of these feelings probably the most
well-known one which is called majolic
extremist
so
still no fault they're going to be one
functions but not for you
so let's say we have a balanced Boolean
function
and let's take some correlation
parameter wrong I encourage you to think
of force close to one say one more steps
I Define the stability of G of f to be
the probability that when I take X and Y
which I will correlated
so what correlated in this stock is
exactly as a Non-Stop in the max stock
the same thing you keep the coordinates
the same with four video and otherwise
it will sample it
for example X and Y whichever correlated
then you ask what is the probability
that F assigns the same value to X and
one
so this is the stability and the
question is what function maximizes the
stability a manual balance functions
well this is a bit of a boring question
it's just Spectators
today many times
and it did if you just take f of x to be
equal to X1 you can calculate the
stability and you can prove that this is
the best you can do
so this is not an interesting question
and it turns out that for PCP the
interesting question is what happens if
you disallow dictators in a strong sense
what happens if I impose on you the
constraint that F has no inferential
variants
and it turns out that the answer is much
more interesting
and morally speaking it says that among
all of the functions with small
influences
the one that maximizes the stability is
the majority function
and
before we still in at least the original
one by Mo uses some very fancy analysis
super functions in particular
hyperconductivity which we've seen the
imbalance principle which we haven't
seen but probably we'll see at some
point in this semester
I should say that this column has
multiple approvement now some of these
some of these don't use any of these
tools but not and we get even better
parameters but uh
we thought excited the motivation for
this statement became precisely because
of the study of UDC
and this led to the development of nice
and it did like two weeks
yeah
negative in the wrong functions of the
Rice Festival was invented to solve this
question Okay so
the statement that a lot of the tools
that were developed with the world the
main motivation of the early motivation
was UDC it is
found many other applications
so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
some problems about winning games which
is two to one games
yeah
so
what is it two to one game
so is everything in the stock two to one
game is a level instance
but you have some additional starting
so basically two to one game is
it's close to any games as you can get
without being
in other words
now maybe that for better not the same
but the left side is the most is just
twice as much as the right side
and now if you look at the constraint as
a graph it's not a matching but it's a
two one regular box
but it is
a very natural
and here is an example
so again we have a usual picture we have
a background graph
and now let's imagine that the labels of
the left side are elements from f 2 to
the K plus one
and the uh maybe the K plus one should
be on the top it doesn't matter
so this alphabet is twice as large as
big supplement think about it as a
vector over F2 of a length K plus 1 and
K
now how would a two to one constraint
look like with this regard well here is
one type of constraint you can look at
so suppose for each Edge I have some
Subspace so again this you should think
of it as F2 to the K plus one so it's a
vector space of Dimension yes
so imagine that for each head I have a
soft base of four dimension one
then what I can do is look at the label
of the left side
project it onto that Subspace and ask
whether this is equal
on the right
so you can observe it because we are in
F2 and we did a project around the core
Dimension One
this is a two to one
constraints because each projected
Vector has two lists too loud in space
so two to one games have been also they
proposed by Court any conjunction but
they are also hard
and if you notice now we don't have this
satisfiability issue because
when you do the uh
propagation algorithms
so you can be optimistic about two to
one games and hope that maybe they'll
have even in the year's case we're
asking to satisfy all of the constraints
I mean the Notions we ask not to satisfy
even Epsilon function of the constraints
but formally speaking this is what is
called the two to one games conjecture
and the theorem which as I said
is equivalent to something oh roughly
equivalent to something about winning
games says that well normally speaking
this conjecture is true
except for the satisfiability issue
in other words foreign
so that if I give you a two to one games
instance so it's MPR to tell whether
it's almost fully satisfiable
namely you can satisfy one reception of
the constraints oh it's barely satisfied
namely you cannot even do Epson
so let me quickly tell you what this
theorem does give you it doesn't give
you all of the Power Rafi gives you half
of the power of ugc
if you have some concrete examples
so as I said it gives you hard gap
between the games within half an
epsilono
and you get some improvements for some
classical
Community or optimization problems for
example you get the fact of square root
of two so both schedule
you get something for click and you get
something more max Bank Max card game
coloring problems and this and that
so I don't want to talk about too much
about these applications I just want to
show you one of them
because this is the problem that we
started doing so if you remember I asked
you what happens if I promise to you
that you know the graph contains a click
of size half
well we cannot quite deal with that
right now but we can say that you know
some different number 0.29
so even if your graph contains a click
of that size you are not going to even
be able to find a click of size electron
so this now we do know but you know
potentially this could go up to half
yeah so to infinity and beyond this Buzz
Lightyear said so
so so now we are going to go into more
of the Boolean analysis type
questions and kind of ask yourself
so let's talk about this uni games
business then there is this two to one
thing and I'm going to try to argue that
if you want to have any hope of
approaching UDC or even this two to one
you need to depart from these classical
Notions of hyperconductivity and small
cell expansion and go beyond that
so in the rest of the time that I have
I'm going to try to motivate why is that
is the case
and then in the next hour and maybe
tomorrow I'm going to say a little bit
more about
but I know it's going to be you know
some very light motivation
but before that are there any questions
before we switch years
so
better if you want to pull TCP results
you have to use what is called L
collecting codes
and more specifically you have to talk
about locally testable quality goals
so what is the locally testable hello
coding code well first of all let's say
that I have a code C which is a subset
of Sigma to the n
I'm going to say that it is not really
testable if I have some tester a
randomized tester
access to some world
s a few locations hopefully concept
demanding
and then based on what it reads it
decides whether to accept projects
and I want two properties to hold
first of all I want it to be the case
that if my tester C is being run on an
actual codeword for my code C
then it's always going to accept
because you can relax it to almost
always accept but for us we're going to
deal with the perfect competence case
but it is usually it happens just
because you design the test out in some
sensible way
and the more interesting part is the
sounds
and the sound that I specified here is
for what is called small soundness and
it proceeds as follows
suppose I had some more W such that if I
run my test on it then it accepts with
non-negligible probability data
how can it be well one case is if I took
an actual codeword and maybe it was a
little bit a little bit and be something
to it then it is most likely to be the
case that the tester is still going to
accept with good probability
says that essentially this is the only
way you can do it
in other words
if T accepts the word w with some
non-negligible probability Delta
then it must be the case the W is
correlated with some actual codeword C
from the code
this is sometimes referred to as the
local to Global phenomenon literature
but don't do learning too much
foreign so here's an example probably
one of the more well-known examples this
is the blam Ruby Ruben linearity desktop
and it procedes as follows
in this case we have the code C which
consists of all of the truth tables of
all linear functions from Z1 to then to
zero one
so this is a network quality code it's
fully legitimate
and you can ask how can we test whether
function is linear or not
so the maps natural test and this is the
tester that the purpose is as follows
stick to inputs X and Y uniformly
condoms
and query the function at three
locations X Y and X plus one
and then just check that these values
add up just check that f of x plus Y is
equal to X Plus F of Y
and if so accept
so it's trivial to see that if f is
linear then the test passes with
probability one
and
author but not trivial to show that if
the test passes with slightly better
probability than half
so coffee is going to be trivial just
Satisfied by a random function
so if you pass it with probably slightly
more than half then it must be the case
that you are correlated with a linear
function
so this is the type of test that you are
after
and let me just mention one more
parameter of Interest which is the
number of queries that the tester makes
so in this test the tester looks at
three values of f namely it needs to
make three queries to the one
and the number four is the tester Max is
going to be important for us
so for the rest of the talk I'm going to
focus on testers T that only make two
queries
so I only allow you to look at two
values of the function or whatever code
we look at
so therefore this type of test is not
going to be interesting for us
we're only going to one two points
so here is a PCP conventional wisdom
which says that everybody believes that
this is true until we don't
and
so the conventional wisdom is that if
you want to pull the harness result for
some problem
let's say some constraints satisfaction
problem
then in order to do that you have to
find a suitable code C
along with a texture
and you need several properties to hold
first of all the tester
has to be complete a sound in the sense
that we just defined
secondly the test though so the tester
you know looks in some values does some
computation and decides whether to
accept the object
so it turns out that oh the conventional
wisdom is that if you want to use this
tester to prove harness result for
something
then the check that the tester does has
to be of the type that you want to do
for example if you want to pull harness
result for it's really you know
then the tester is going to have to look
at three locations
and check a linear equation in the few
of them
so as well so this is the first thing
that you want
and the second thing is well you know
I'll collecting coins we think of them
as encoding some message by a longer
string
and the conventional wisdom says that
you don't want the blow up of this
encoding to be too much
and
I should say it say that this reasoning
seems kind of inherent it seems that
there is no way around it
but the other is a bit more technical in
nature unfortunately I'm not going to be
able to
fully tell you why it's necessary this
is related to step in this proof that is
called composition where you take some
PCP you take your tester and you combine
them to get something nice
and when you look at it you see that you
don't want this block to be too much
and here's actually a good point to
remark why
UDC makes our life easier when we prove
our potential results
because basically if you are willing to
assume UDC then you can ignore this
conditional
any blog will do
therefore if you want to design Harvest
results based on UDC you just need to
find the tester which is complete and
sound and uses the right type of
check and you're good
and if you heard the word long code then
actually you don't have even much choice
of what the code is just take long
audits if anything exists it will exist
in a long code so it doesn't leave too
much maneuvering space
so this is why you see is nice to have
but if you are not willing to assume
that then you need this
low-up condition
and I would like to argue that
the two properties of the blow up in the
soundness are actually in tension with
each other
so I'm soon going to tell you that if
you want the test to be sound
then there is a graph that you can
associate with the test the test will be
responsive expander
otherwise there is no way this this is
going to be some
on the other end
if you have only a small blower in your
code
is to play around with
therefore this limits the type of
testers that you can choose
and naturally when you don't have too
much freedom in your testers this means
that you're going to have trouble making
this test graph that I'm going to soon
Define a muscle expandable
so there is a delicate tension here
between one thing the test of to be
smaller expander but wanting it to be
cheap with the blowout
and this is where this conventional
wisdom is going to eventually break
we're going to have to give up on one of
these
getting ahead of myself
okay
so in the last five minutes I'm going to
tell you what this test stuff is and
tell you why small cell expansion seems
inherent
so let's say that we have a code see we
want to coordinate spaces anal
now I'm going to Define the Gulf whose
vertex says uh the coordinates of the
code
and I have an edge between two locations
if they can be queried by the tester
thing
so what is the test essentially doing
well the tester is just speaking in
adding this stuff
calling the two locations and asking and
deciding whether to accept the project
and my claim is that if you want your
tester T to be sound
then this graph GP has to be smarter
expanding
and the proof is going to be by picture
so let's move it so suppose this graph
GT is not small service bundle
therefore it means that I can find some
small set that has a lot of edges inside
it
for more sensible tests they have some
symmetry books so therefore once I have
one set I can find many sets so let's
say there's a bunch of sets let's want
to ascend that are disjoint they took a
together have a large fraction of the
vertices and each one of them is
individually expansion which is one of
the way for one
then once I have this then I can show
you a word that passes the test with
nice probability but it's not
it doesn't come from any codeword
actually
so what I can do is you know I have
these sets
which one of them I can choose a
completely different code order
and assign the coordinates in S1
according to C1 according test to
connect two and so on and so forth
then you can observe that because the
tester if it looks two locations inside
X2 it's only going to look locally C2
therefore it's going to accept
and because you cover a lot of vertices
and inside each set a lot of the edges
stay in you can show that the tester
passes with constant probability
but because of because each one of these
sets is small you don't actually have a
code word globally it's all a lot of
small codewords
yeah so this basically completes the
proof of why small cell expansion is
necessary if you want this that is there
to be sound
so so this is the model if you want to
be sound you have to have an SSE
so is it
so it is it is necessary but what this
suggests is that if we want to get over
this other
then we must give up on SSU
we need to work with graphs that are not
muscle expanders and see how to get over
this hump
and try to do some other things
and in my next two talks the one after
this in 30 minutes and the one two more
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
how you can go beyond it and I'm going
to tell you about this gas one goth and
all of the things associated with it
which sort of uh
which again will motivated purely by PCB
perspective and while this lens of
global conductivity really started
so I'm going to talk about this and
we'll see where we go
so that's it next up thank you
are there any questions follow
limitation is something like that hold
even for more queries than two is
so it's not complicated to even
formulated for more calories so for some
problems you're lucky for example during
your life because somehow you can allow
yourself a Docker correction using the
trick tool so whenever this is mechanism
this limitation doesn't really exist but
when this when you're alone then I'm
guessing that some limitations
okay uh
but this depends on what is the problem
you are trying to prevalence for so if
you want School works for example
you need to take a high alphabet you can
always do trivially someone support like
one over there
um
foreign foreign
[Applause]